hey mom strim fans I hope everyone is
doing okay thanks to Cove in nineteen
I'm stuck at home as you likely are too
so I thought I'd give you a peek into
how my monster loving brain prepares for
the inevitable zombie outbreak or robot
apocalypse bioterrorism attack nuclear
war alien invasion major solar flare
finding out the matrix is real the great
flood supervolcano sharknado he's rising
up and taking revenge giant mutant
insects
I mean pandemic whatever I'm ready so
I'm going to show you what's in my
go-bag my bug out bag bug in bag get out
of dodge bag basically the bag I keep in
my car stocked full of survival
necessities and Cait it's the fan or
should I say what it does I'm dr. emily
szarka and this is monstrum when
resources become scarce it's quickly
apparent who is prepared and who is not
sure you could go full survivalist mode
and stalk an underground bunker or
secret cabin in the woods with months
worth of food water and toilet paper but
that kind of preparation isn't realistic
for many people and likely isn't
necessary so where can you look to
figure out what will keep you safe and
even more importantly help you get in
the right mindset to survive in a
life-threatening situation horror
stories horror books and films shape my
life obviously yeah I study monsters for
a living but there are other day-to-day
things like always making sure where the
exits are and what object in the room
could be used as a weapon some
legitimate organizations like the CDC
and FEMA have some great survivalist
tips and those are definitely worth
looking at but there's also a few things
missing from their checklist that I
think can be the difference between
staying alive and becoming zombie food
although I was a Girl Scout and taught
to always be prepared
I really didn't start stacking the deck
in my favor until I began watching
horror movies as
let's be clear a lot of it is nuts
some of it is outright ridiculous
but there are some very useful tidbits
and horror stories that you can use in
real life yes I keep a go-bag in my car
yes I pretty much always have a stocked
pantry with two weeks worth of
non-perishable food and yes I have a
zombie apocalypse survival team of
people I vetted who possess the skills
and mindset necessary to survive an
outbreak of the undead
call me crazy but my survivor mindset
means I'm ready for the worst if it
happens whether that's my car breaking
down at night in the snow or a sudden
hoard of the Living Dead before we get
into my go-bag let's talk about horror
movies and how they inspired me to
become more prepared I for one have
learned plenty of things while
delightfully watching horror movies here
are just a few examples Night of the
Living Dead finding food should be a
priority then securing and barricading
your location and honestly that is just
one of the most competent Bourne movie
characters out there you're next no bug
out bag here but an excellent example of
how resourcefulness and survival
training can save your life even when
you're in an unfamiliar territory
28 days later and 28 weeks later let me
know that you can't always trust
Authority or anyone who broadcast
shelter and if a huge group of animals
starts running in one direction you run
in that same direction plus a plastic
bag full of soda and money is useless -
temporarily disarming is off there are
also some helpful examples of what a
good go bag looks like Bushwick has a
pretty decent one there's a first-aid
kit with scissors gauze and rubbing
alcohol a flare pain meds water a
flashlight a knife duct tape and a
sewing kit all of which come in handy in
one way or another throughout the movie
all right so now it's time for what is
actually in my bag so this is my bag I
know some people say that I should
probably have like a pack bag or
something with an internal frame but
this one was free it was my brother's
old backpack and it has lots of pockets
which helps keep me organized so this is
what I have right now so let's see
what's in the bag I keep this on the
right side for easy access sort of my
like the defence pocket a knife kind of
self-explanatory but knife is always
good to have a hand sanitizer Flint this
is a fire starter that I highly
recommend that you practice with this it
can be hard to get the hang of right
away and the last thing you want when
you actually need it is having to spend
an hour trying to get a spark tiny
alcohol bottle alcohol is always a
valuable resource to have for bartering
and to actually sterilize wounds in a
last-ditch effort if you need to
pepper spray gun I like this one because
it has a really far shot and I actually
have two shots again protection from
other people workman's gloves please get
these you ever read the road or seeing
the movie the road having these is
really important flashlight this one is
awesome because it's actually a hand
crank so I don't need batteries or any
electricity to use it and it always
works my multi-purpose tool definitely
important to have some kind of basic
multi-purpose tool this one also comes
with an additional flashlight one other
really important thing to have in your
survival kit is some kind of can opener
so this is a japanese-style one it's
really simple relatively lightweight
not super bulky doesn't take up a lot of
space waterproof matches allergy pills
I'm allergic to shellfish and have some
other allergies so this is something
super important to me the moral of this
story is keep around medication that you
need personally so if you have anything
you take on a day-to-day basis I would
recommend trying to get an extra 30 day
supply of that and keeping it in your go
bag just in
a quarter now moving to the interior
pocket floor workman's gloves you can
never have too many and if you're
traveling with someone else and they
don't have them you're good to go a
blanket for staying warm or helping
build a shelter yes I did take this from
an airplane don't touch me
deck of cards for entertainment but also
for bartering purposes people are gonna
be bored for the apocalypse maybe they
want something to do and they have a lot
of canned food you get food they get a
source of entertainment everyone wins
face masks for protection this was
important in Hand Crank and solar
powered radio and let's say the
electricity is cut off or the new
stations are down you can't get on the
Internet
I can have a little form of staying on
top of everything Oh an emergency
blanket this emergency blanket can keep
you warm which might be important if
someone goes into shock or if it's
nighttime and you're freezing but also
they're reflective emergency rations
they have almost 4,000 calories in each
bar there's enough for one person for
three days in here
tastes like shortbread it's actually not
terrible duct tape if you buy anything
by duct tape and as infinite uses you
can't go wrong with duct tape it's not a
life straw this allows me to drink from
natural water sources that might not be
safe otherwise so I know I can get water
by having one of these handy Oh first
aid kit absolutely crucial to have a
first aid kit I also keep some expired
medications some pain meds and
antibiotics in here you never know when
you might need them during the
apocalypse oh this one's fun so I know I
said that horror movies were what really
got me on my sort of survivalist journey
but one thing that really started it is
this book The Zombie Survival Guide and
yes it does talk a lot about how to kill
zombies the best weapons to do so but I
think it's really important it talks
about things like protection how to
remain invisible look and listen you
know
Wilbanks
now not only is entertaining but it
reminds me of sort of where my
survivalist journey started Oh emergency
poncho more hand sanitizer so I have a
pair of socks because I keep a pair of
old sneakers in my bag as well after
watching some of you you know disaster
movies where you see these women running
around in high heels all the time that's
impractical and you could hurt yourself
so I always keep extra pair of shoes and
socks so I have more secure stable
footwear if I need it then I also keep
this guy the art of eating through the
zombie apocalypse what I really like
about this is that it teaches you how to
do things like pickle vegetables make a
makeshift fishing line how to clean and
gut animals have some great recipes for
canned food and air dried food also I
like that it sort of encourages mindset
where it's not just about survival but
about being comfortable so even things
like using spices to help make your
canned food not so terrible or
monotonous keep this one handy and
finally I have a notebook and a pen not
only to keep notes for myself or if I
needed to like make a sign or something
but I actually took an urban survival
class a few years ago and I have all my
notes in here so things about how to
purify different kinds of water basic
food starter kit that kind of stuff so
yeah that's my go bag we've been doing
this for a long time apocalypse
scenarios feature heavily in many
religions from the Norse Ragnarok
to the events described in the Bible's
Book of Revelations
but these end-of-days stories go back
even further to around 2000 BC an epic
of gilgamesh which features a huge flood
but what keeps us drawn to all these
apocalyptic tales watching a scary movie
or reading a terrifying book offers more
than entertainment we get to experience
danger without actually being in harm's
way
in other words it's kind
like an emotional and intellectual
practice for our brains to learn how to
react in the mid 18th century
philosopher Edmund Burke proposed that
humans could experience something like
delight when encountering the sublime
something that evokes the idea of danger
and pain without actually posing an
immediate threat this is why we enjoy
rollercoasters haunted houses and of
course horror movies as Burke says at
certain distances and with certain
modifications like a movie screen for
instance we can experience delight the
relief of not being the person who is
suffering there are lessons we can learn
from horror even if there is no specific
monster to point a finger at how
characters in fiction respond to
dangerous situations can help form our
own habits the overall takeaway be
prepared but please for the love of God
there's no reason to hoard toilet paper
and hey if Ron Swanson can have an
emergency Tammy bag in case his ex-wife
shows up you can keep a few things in
your car or desk at work Godspeed